And this
morning, two
Tennessee National Guardsmen were killed
after their Blackhawk
helicopter crashed
during a training flight
and went down Wednesday on a highway
in northern Alabama.
Look at that video.
Goodness, I'm a walker.
Joins us now live from Atlanta.
Amara, that's frightening.
What do you know?
Yeah, it is frightening.
And I can tell you, witnesses
there on the ground described
quite a shocking scene
over the skies of northern Alaba
We don't know a lot right now.
We're still working to get detai
on what exactly led up to this
deadly Black Hawk helicopter cra
and more on the two Tennessee
National Guardsmen
who were killed in this incident
But as you mentioned,
this happened
during a routine training flight
video capturing the moment
when a Tennessee National Guard
helicopter crashes
near a highway
in northern Alabama Wednesday.
That's pretty loud.
And it didn't sound like a norma
I guess, motor or engine.
Anything really is
followed by a plume of smoke
coming up over the trees
looking out of binoculars
and seeing what I saw.
I can't do anything but pray.
What was
the two Guardsmen on board
the helicopter were killed.
In a press
release posted on Twitter,
the Tennessee National Guard con
the helicopter involved a
UAH 60 Blackhawk out on a traini
and saying
we are deeply saddened
by the loss of two Tennessee
National Guardsmen.
And our prayers are with their f
during this heartbreaking traged
The crash occurred Wednesday
around three P.
M local time
along the median of highway
53 near Huntsville, Alabama.
First
responders arrived at the scene
where the military helicopter
was fully engulfed in flames
and video captured
by motorists showed thick black
smoke coming from the site.
But federal and local authoritie
are investigating the crash
and no other service
members or civilians were injure
in the incident.
Governors of both Tennessee
and Alabama are offering
their condolences.
Tennessee Governor Bill Lee sayi
please join us in
lifting their families up in pra
and support
during this time of unspeakable
And Alabama
Governor Kay Ivey
saying the Guardsmen will be rem
as heroes.
And the people of Alabama
stand with our neighbors in Tenn
and first responders said
when they got on scene
that the helicopter
was fully engulfed in flames,
that it had completely burned do
And that's why
it was so difficult to identify
And it took some time, took quit
for officials to figure out who
this Black Hawk helicopter.
But look, if you look at those p
it is quite remarkable
that no one else was injured
there on the ground, Don.
Amazing.
And caught on video,
I think is like a ring doorbell,
doorbell, surveillance camera.
Thank you, Amara Walker. Appreci